hahaha sometimes I wish let me just
disappear the illness it looks like I'm
wearing both the rest of my life and
I'll go to tights that capes just gotta
be annoying I've great thighs so I would
rather wear ties hey Katie takes it very
comfortable it's like second skin look
that's you I'll take the cake
Black Widow oh I don't even know what
the rest of the question was but if I
get to choose something to do with my
Black Widow I'll take them both because
they're both amazing
I think I think I would bring a Black
Widow home she could probably easier to
explain I don't know
are those all euphemism screw it I know
right I gotta say Wolverines claws
because the other one doesn't sound
right
oh god I'd rather be tickled by
Wolverine claws I don't want no other
man rubbing me with his hammock tickled
with Wolverines claws
if he hadn't had caffeine in it I like
to travel so I think I'd like to go
check out Aska dark hour start our like
then as good 10 housewife start our
uh-oh
stalk time well ant-man because I feel
like spider-man within our film anyways
so young it's that would be creepy man
that stuff uh and at least he can drink
I would rather be stuck on a deserted
island with the vision because I just I
love purple
Scarlet Witch I wish you can do that
stuff and like catch fish zing brats I'm
gonna say the vision just because he
might be able to fly me out of the hole
does the Hulk can bus out of mail
low-key okay so I do get really
claustrophobic with the whole I don't
think it would fit any probably worries
a lot of cologne anyway no no okay
low-key elevator with the Hulk you're
almost guaranteed to die I would rather
be invisible I think you have a lot of
opportunities to get into mischief
I think being physical might be a lot of
fun I'll go invisible cuz there's more
times in my life I wish I learned this
one smells awful took that let me touch
disappear
that's all I can see through anything
yes x-ray visions it's gonna be long
I would rather have x-ray vision you can
rather have super speed but if we talk
about the drug or I know you man I still
take sometimes RDJ man I would rather be
on team arm I'm gonna say team cat I
would rather be on team cap black widows
on a team Iron Man so let's do it